quante volte in un giorno guardiamo il
cielo o in una notte limpida camminiamo
con il naso all'insù per ammirare la
luna osservare le stelle identificare le
costellazioni e magari qualche pianeta
un po più luminoso degli altri
il cielo ha sempre affascinato l'uomo ci
fa pensare a chi siamo da dove veniamo
quale sarà il nostro futuro gli antichi
per millenni hanno osservato il cielo a
occhio nudo hanno identificato i pianeti
calcolato le orbite calcolato la
posizione delle stelle usato il cielo
per misurare il tempo poi nel novembre
del 1609 a padova c'è stato un signore
di nome galileo che ha puntato per la
prima volta un telescopio di mentale
verso la luna e non avendo una macchina
fotografica ha disegnato quello che
vedeva e quei disegni sono uguali alle
foto di oggi
galileo copernico tico bra e keplero
hanno raccolto l'eredità di migliaia di
anni di osservazioni ad occhio nudo e
dato il via a quella che noi oggi
conosciamo come astronomia da terra
quattrocento anni dopo è partita alla
conquista dello spazio
nell'anno mondiale della geofisica al 4
ottobre del 1957 dalla base russa di
baikonur è stato lanciato il primo
satellite artificiale della terra lo
sputnik un oggetto piuttosto grosso 83
kg che dentro non aveva praticamente
niente una batteria l'antenna per dire
dov'era il 31 gennaio del 1958 dalla
base di cape canaveral è partito un
oggetto decisamente più leggero circa 14
kg l'explorer 1 che però a bordo aveva
dei rivelatori di particelle dei
detector che sono gli occhiali che
indossiamo per osservare la natura e
capire come funziona sono gli occhiali
che ci aiutano a trovare risposte alle
nostre domande
io sono un fisico che disegna occhiali
per osservare la natura
l'ex ploner prenderà dati per 111 giorni
e scoprirà le fasce di van allen ma in
quei 400 anni
i fisici si sono resi conto che
l'universo ci raccontava un sacco di
storie in più rispetto a quello che si
aspettava galileo perché la luce
e solo una piccola parte della
radiazione elettromagnetica onde con
lunghezza d'onda di qualche centinaio di
nanometri ma io potrei tranquillamente
parlarvi delle onde radio che hanno
lunghezze bonde di decine centinaia di
metri che noi a terra usiamo per
ascoltare le trasmissioni radiofoniche e
ci sono galassie che emettono onde radio
oppure microonde come quelle che noi a
terra usiamo per scaldare cibi oppure
infrarossi che sono quelli che atterra
usiamo per cambiare canale alla tv e
potrei continuare così per tutto lo
spettro elettromagnetico fino ad
arrivare alle onde con la lunghezza
d'onda più piccola in assoluto i raggi
xe i raggi gamma che sono quelli che
usiamo per guardare dentro il vostro
corpo quando vi facciamo una radiografia
o per curare con la radioterapia un
paziente malato di tumore
dovete pensare all universo come un
bellissimo romanzo pensato a un romanzo
giallo in cui ogni capitolo è scritto in
una lingua diversa e ogni capitolo è una
bellissima storia a sé però se non siete
capaci di leggerli tutti non riuscirete
mai a risolvere il mistero e trovare chi
è il colpevole allora il compito dei
fisici come me che disegnano occhiali
per osservare la natura detector è
quello di disegnare occhiali che ci
permettano di leggere ogni singolo
capito mettere insieme e trovare il
colpevole allora ben venga la luce
visibile di galileo ma non semplicemente
coi telescopi messi a terra noi abbiamo
messo dei telescopi sopra l'atmosfera
perché così ci siamo liberatì delle
perturbazioni dell'area e abbiamo visto
anche raggi infrarossi e raggi
ultravioletti che a terra non arrivano
il 24 aprile del 1990 è stato messo in
orbita il telescopio hubble un oggetto
enorme un gigante nella parte più grande
ha un diametro di 4 metri è più lungo di
un autobus pesa più di 11 mila kg ha
bisogno di 2.100 vatta per funzionare e
far fotografie fotografie come i vostri
cellulari un po più grandi un po più
precisi ma fotografie fotografie come
questa questa è la fotografia di un
ammasso globulare di stelle centinaia di
migliaia a volte milioni di stelle che
si sono tutte formate nello stesso
momento e se io tramite queste immagini
riesco a misurare la luna
novità di queste stelle paragonarla a
quella del sole sono capace di dire
quanti anni hanno gli ammassi globulari
di stelle sono i nostri orologi cosmici
e confermano che il nostro universo a
circa 13.7 miliardi di anni
e se invece ci spostiamo nella parte
dello spettro con le onde con la
lunghezza d'onda più piccola in assoluto
i raggi gamma
la storia che vi racconto è
completamente diversa dagli inizi del
1900 noi fisici
parliamo indifferentemente di particelle
onde ce l'hanno insegnato ai sane
colleghi particelle onde sono la stessa
cosa
il risultato è tutta l'elettronica che
voi utilizzate ogni giorno i raggi gamma
sono fotoni cioè particelle prive di
carica e di massa che quindi se quando
vengono emesse da una sorgente sono in
grado di fare una marea di strada senza
risentire di niente e se non le vediamo
identifichiamo le sorgenti in questo
modo possiamo studiare le sorgenti più
energetiche dell'universo quale
rappresentative dei fenomeni più
catastrofici dell'universo possiamo
cercare la voce del big bang e se
vogliamo vedere i raggi gamma di
altissima energia
costruiamo a terra degli specchi di 90
centimetri di diametro che poi mettiamo
insieme a costruire specchi giganti di
centinaia di metri quadri di area che
catturano la luce emesse dalle
particelle prodotte da questi raggi
gamma
quando arrivano all'interno
dell'atmosfera
e se invece vogliamo vedere dei raggi
gamma con un'energia un po più bassa
mettiamo un satellite sopra d'atmosfera
e questo è quello che ho fatto anch'io
io ho partecipato alla costruzione del
satellite agile astro rivelatore gamma a
immagini leggero un satellite
dell'agenzia spaziale italiana che deve
aiutarci a leggere il capitolo dei raggi
gamma dei raggi ics
io mi sono occupata del cuore del
satellite un cubo di circa 45 centimetri
di lato
tutto fatto di rivelatori al silicio che
sono gli stessi rivelatori che stanno
dentro i vostri cellulari dentro le
vostre macchine fotografiche dentro i
vostri personal computer dentro tutta
l'elettronica che avete che sono i
rivelatori che usiamo per vedere i raggi
ics quando vi facciamo una tac è in
pratica una piccola macchina fotografica
in cui questi raggi gamma invisibili
diventano pixel accesi per cui io posso
ricostruire da dire
da qui arrivano e identificare la
sorgente poi questo cuore assieme ad
altri rivelatori è stato messo nel
satellite con i suoi pannelli solari per
catturare l'energia del sole
i sensori stellari per capire dove siamo
la coperta termica perché quando di
fronte al sole sente caldo ma quando
nell'ombra della terra ha parecchio
freddo e questo oggetto di pochi più di
350 kg è stato inserito nel missine ed è
partito il 23 aprile del 2007 dalla base
indiana di sriharikota 20 minuti ed è
arrivato in orbita 540 chilometri di
altezza orbita equatoriale angolo di 2.5
gradi
novanta minuti dopo passando sopra la
base a terra di malindi ci ha fatto ciao
da dimostrarci che era ancora tutto
intero e da dieci anni ha compiuto 10
anni un mese e mezzo fa osserva le
profondità dell'universo e ci fa vedere
sorgenti che appaiono e scompaiono ci ha
fatto cambiare idea su sorgenti che
pensavamo funzionassero in tutt'altro
modo
ci fa leggere il capitolo dei raggi
gamma
ma i raggi gamma non solo gli unici
messaggeri catastrofici energetici
dell'universo ognuno di noi ha
attraversato ogni secondo da svariati
miliardi di neutrini e non se ne accorge
i neutrini sono particelle di
piccolissima massa che non hanno carica
quindi anche loro quando sono emessi
dalla sorgente fanno una marea di strada
senza che niente possa fermarli il
problema è che sono particelle elusive
cioè interagiscono a poco con la materia
nel frattempo che io parlo di qua
saranno passati decine di milioni di
miliardi di neutrini e nel frattempo che
io ho finito quali saranno già oltre
l'orbita di marte
l'unico modo che abbiamo per vederli è
usare tanta materia e sperare che
interagiscano e la materia più facile da
trovare sulla terra e l'acqua per questo
motivo ai fisici giapponesi di super
kamiokande hanno riempito un'intera
miniera la miniera di kamioka 1000 metri
sottoterra con 50mila tonnellate di
acqua pura e poi hanno piastrellato
tutte le pareti della miniera
con questi oggetti che si chiamano
fotomoltiplicatori hanno un diametro di
50 centimetri funzionano come i nostri
occhi vedono la luce
perché l'unico modo per vedere un
neutrino è che quando interagisce col
protone o con neutrone delle molecole
d'acqua emette elettroni oi suoi
fratelli un po più pesanti i nuovi che
nell'acqua vanno più veloci della
velocità della luce
nell'acqua perché la luce la cosa più
veloce in assoluto nel vuoto 300.000
chilometri al secondo
ma in un mezzo le particelle possono
essere più veloci e allora emettono luce
si chiama radiazione cerenkov e una
radiazione blu l'unico modo che abbiamo
per vedere i neutrini e fotografare la
luce che deriva dalla loro interazione
con l'acqua e se non volete riempire di
acqua una miniera
usiamo il ghiaccio ice cube al polo sud
un chilometro cubo di ghiaccio pozzi
profondi 2820 metri scavati da trivelle
che vanno a 2 metri al minuto in cui tra
latte velocemente queste colonne di
fotomoltiplicatori che sono le nostre
macchine fotografiche e poi il ghiaccio
richiude tutto è quello che fanno queste
macchine fotografiche e fotografare la
luce emessa dalle particelle prodotte
dai neutrini quando attraversano la
terra e in questo modo ice cube ha visto
i tre neutrini più energetici che si
siano mai visti sulla terra hanno
un'energia è andato persino un nome
hanno un'energia che è centinaia di
volte quella dei protoni che facciamo a
scontrare a lhc al cern sono briciole di
big bang e nell'emisfero boreale invece
del ghiaccio usiamo l'acqua km trenet
nel mediterraneo tolone la grecia 80
chilometri a sud est di capo passero in
sicilia a 3.500 metri di profondità col
onde di queste macchine fotografiche tra
virgolette che devono anche resistere
alle correnti marine e non andarsene
dove vogliono
per fotografare la luce emessa dai
neutrini quando interagiscono con
l'acqua del mare e farci leggere così il
romanzo dell'universo l'esplorazione
dell'universo è un viaggio bellissimo il
5 settembre del 1977 è partita dalla
base di cape canaveral
la sonda voyager 1 dove la fotografare
da vicino alcuni pianeti il 14 febbraio
del 1990 si trovava 6 miliardi
di chilometri dalla terra ci ha
fotografati e ci ha mandato questa foto
questa foto è nota come per il blu dotta
il pallido puntino blu o anche cerchiato
il puntino per farvi vedere dove siamo
carlo pagan famoso astronomo e
divulgatore di questa foto diceva e qui
è casa e noi tutti coloro che amate
tutti coloro che conoscete tutti coloro
che siano mai esistiti hanno vissuto qui
nell'unica casa che abbiamo questo
pallido puntino blu tra 300 anni
la sonda voyager 1 arriverà nella patria
delle comete la nube di oort ma a quel
punto la sorgente di plutonio che fa
funzionare l'antenna si sarà esaurita e
non potrà più comunicare con noi sarà ai
nostri occhi e le nostre orecchie ma noi
non sapremo quello che vede è quello che
sente ma non per questo ci arrenderemo
perché esplorando l'universo ascoltiamo
la voce del nostro passato
cerchiamo risposte alle nostre domande
esplorando l'universo disegniamo il
nostro futuro perché cresciamo non solo
come scienziati ma cresciamo soprattutto
come uomini
grazie
[Applauso]